aux côtés de la délégation française
c'est la première étape important de
cette visite à l'ukraine étape
évidemment hautement symbolique
oui hautement symbolique car l'endroit
où nous nous trouvons on en rêve peut
dire qu'il a été bombardé sans relâche
des p ô ma part les rues il y avait
notamment un hôpital militaire et flic
ou retrouvons c'est pour ça notamment
que cet endroit avait été énormément
bombarder tous les bâtiments autour de
nous sont en ruine les meubles les
maisons le quartier a été vraiment en
juin extrêmement bombardé et chevalet
avec des photos du quartier avant qu'il
ne soit pas bon mardion été installé
devant un ps immeubles pour montrer aux
dirigeants qui se trouvent ici bien
comment était le quartier avant on se
trouve également pas très loin de
l'aéroport militaire d'hosto mail qui se
trouve à environ 8 où une quinzaine de
kilomètres ils avaient aussi bombardé
sans relâche par les récents mois de
mars et là que se trouve est rappelé aux
aéronefs du monde un manteau d'un ce qui
avait été entièrement détruits pendant
les bombardements et maniait le
maquereau lors de cette visite autour de
ce petit quartier de syrte il a demandé
à plusieurs reprises quand les habitants
pourrait revenir ici les autorités lui
ont répondu que pour l'instant il avait
évalué le montant des dommages et il
espérait que la reconstruction a détruit
très assise assez rapidement et il a été
déclarée ville héros par décret
présidentiel du président volodymyr
velde qui est le président français on
imagine en tant que président également
deux tu conseilles que l'union
européenne est là aussi pour parler de
reconstruction
le crem a besoin d'argent elle compte
sur l'aide européenne selon une première
estimation qui a été fait il y en aurait
pour le moment pour plus de 100
milliards de dollars de dommages tout
tout tout bâtiment confondues en ukraine